Passion, dedication, and barely enough money
to buy a used sofa on Craigslist: these are
the things fan films are made of.
Let's recognize the hard work and talent that
went into some of the best ones.
Batman versus the Terminator
When all hope is lost and humanity’s demise
is certain, here comes the one man crazy enough
to fight murder-robots while dressed as a
bat.
“You picking this up Jon”
The result is Batman versus the Terminator.
In this animated short, not only do fans get
an older, tough-as-nails Batman inspired by
the works of Frank Miller...they also get
Batman mowing down T-800 robo-skeletons in
his Bat-tank in the post-apocalyptic, machine-controlled
Earth from the Terminator movies.
Death Scene Springtrap
In the Five Nights At Freddy's games, players
control a newly hired security guard at a
Chuck E.
Cheese-like restaurant.
It's a quiet night and everything's going
normally, until the creepy animatronic animal
characters come to life.
This fan film adaptation of the game isn’t
even a minute and a half long and yet it still
manages to capture every detail that makes
the game series great.
Spawn: The Recall
In 1997, Spawn hit the big screen—and it
was a disaster.
“Spawny, Spawny he’s our man if he can’t
kill em no one can.
Yeah”
The fan film Spawn: The Recall, succeeds where
Spawn '97 failed.
In it, a child and his mother come face-to-face
with Spawn himself, who has a dire message
that must be delivered.
“Lucifer is back”
Fans nailed Spawn in eight minutes.
The best Hollywood could do was...this.
“That face for me.
Oops”
Our RoboCop Remake
Our RoboCop Remake was an attempt to re-create
or reimagine every scene from the original
1987 RoboCop movie.
Dozens of Los Angeles-area comedians and sketch
groups each picked one scene to make as they
pleased.
In the end, all of their stylistically different
work was stitched together to form one utterly
unique RoboCop.
And it didn't need Michael Keaton or Samuel
L. Jackson, either.
Dirty Laundry
Marvel’s 2004 Punisher movie was a letdown.
Star Thomas Jane more than made up for it
by reprising his role as the vigilante in
a short fan film called Dirty Laundry.
All of Frank Castle's rage and capacity for
lethal violence is unleashed when a normal
laundry day is interrupted by gang violence.
It's brutal, bloody, and actually fun to watch.
Batman: Dead End
Just when a showdown between Batman and the
Joker is about to peak, a new fighter enters
the match: a Xenomorph, the acid-drooling
monster from the Alien movies.
The alien pins Batman …and then someone
else shows up.
And some others.
It doesn't make much sense, but it's awesome.
Severus Snape and the Marauders
Set in 1978, this 25-minute film tells the
story of James Potter—Harry's dad— Sirius
Black, Peter Pettigrew, and Remus Lupin, as
they bully young Severus Snape after he tries
to meet Lily in a bar.
It perfectly captures Snape's inner rage and
conflict as a man who walks the line between
good and evil.
Troops
“Come for you, Tell me what you wanna do,
whats you gonna do”
If there were a fan-film hall of fame, Troops
would be an immediate inductee.
Made in 1997, it's an episode of COPS set
in the Star Wars universe, starring dimwitted
Stormtroopers on Tatooine.
It's groundbreaking for its use of impressive
low-budget CG effects.
Even better?
It's really funny.
Power/Rangers
Part fan-film remake and part parody of dark,
gritty reboots, Power/Rangers takes the kiddie
franchise and tells how each Ranger has spiraled
downward in their Ranger-retirements.
It has a lot more money behind it than most
fan films, and more star power, too, with
appearances from James van der Beek and Battlestar
Galactica's Katee Sackhoff.
Star Wars: Uncut
Star Wars fan Casey Pugh had a wild idea:
a crowdsourced shot-for-shot remake of A New
Hope.
Fans claimed 15-second segments of the film
to remake, and then Pugh edited them together.
One moment Han, Luke, and Obi-Wan are Legos,
and seconds later it's a bunch of kids in
their backyards with broom handles for lightsabers.
A fresh take on a familiar classic, it adds
up to one of the best fan films ever.
Thanks for watching! Subscribe to our YouTube channel to watch more videos like the one you just saw.
And leave us a comment to let us know which fan film you're a fan of...